history has shown us that sometimes the
impossible happens Mikhail Gorbachev
went from leading of a Soviet Union the
face of a North American multinational
company sometimes nothing brings people
together like a nice hot pizza from
Pizza
[Applause]
so we ever see something like this in
North Korea well listen up
[Applause]
[Music]
North Korea is a very very poor country
the available estimates state that their
per capita production value is 50 times
smaller than that of South Korea less
than 1,000 kilometers of their roads are
paved the average life expectancy is the
lowest in the entire region and despite
having received humanitarian aid for
more than 22 years there's still poverty
all over the country
[Music]
but that is not even the worst of it the
worst is a total lack of respect for
human rights
the North Koreans live under an iron
clads dictatorship in the police state
where political prisoners amount to tens
and tens of thousands in fact according
to the United Nations there could be
between eighty and a hundred and twenty
thousand political prisoners in
reeducation camps in North Korea the
state controls everything the hold on
just a moment because in recent years an
important change seems to have occurred
in the country a change that has a lot
to do with money with Commerce and with
the market you see theoretically North
Korea is the last large country the last
large state with a communist ideology
here practically everything is directed
organized manufactured and provided for
by the state including housing health
education food employments etc
but this is all in theory and the truth
the truth is very different you see the
state has a great deal of limitations
basically it's becoming less and less
able to do stuff allow me to explain
many of the states factories and farms
productivity levels are absolutely on
the floor and additionally in many cases
as a result of very old machinery
backwards production methods
international sanctions and even
electrical supply problems for a great
part of their time production centers
they aren't even operative due to all of
this a new private economy has gained
strength in recent years from which more
and more North Koreans now depend in
order to survive and improve their
living standards now hold on just a
second because a private sector in North
Korea with markets and with capitalism
it sounds pretty bizarre but you
absolutely heard right and listen to
this
the new North Korean market Divya when
kim jeong-hoon was officially declared
Supreme Leader that is the absolute
dictator of North Korea on December 28
2011 many analysts thought that things
could change in the country at the end
of the day this was a generational
change that was bringing a 28 year old
into power a 28 year old who'd studied
abroad in Switzerland however it seemed
became clear that some things weren't
going to change
North Korea's new leader Kim jong-un has
turned out to be just as terrible as his
father was the purges the inhuman
punishments the rampant persecution the
leader centered cult sins in short the
complete control of citizens lives have
continued being this regime's
main characteristics it's like a
religion from birth you learn about the
Kim family learn that they are gods that
you must be absolutely obedient to the
Kim family the elites are treated nicely
and because of that they make sure that
the system stays stable but for everyone
else it's a reign of terror a doctor who
worked at a hospital in high Sahn North
Korea and now works as a doctor at a
hospital in South Korea however dear
viewer since Kim jong-un came to power
something surprising has happened dozens
of markets where North Koreans trade
privately have opened throughout the
country a new class of merchants and
entrepreneurs is growing in North Korea
[Music]
in fact according to the Career
Institute for national unification
around 1 million people work directly in
these markets which have already become
one of the main sources of wealth in the
country now you might be wondering right
now Simon hold on a second how did those
markets come about well let me tell you
first that they don't have the most
glamorous or happiest of beginnings
you
you see it all started in the 1990s when
famine caused by government mistakes
lack of resources weather conditions and
the collapse of the Soviet Union wreaks
absolute havoc in the country estimates
state that between 1 to 2 million people
died of starvation well right at the
time went North Koreans were struggling
to survive the first markets arose
places where people could exchange
anything they could get resources with
which they could buy food we realized
that if we did nothing we would die of
hunger so we started to trade Joo young
suddenly dozens and dozens of markets
appeared throughout the country saving
thousands thousands of lives that's
precisely why the regime didn't
persecute to this type of private
activity as you might expect Kim jong-il
the current leaders father let's just
say that sometimes he tolerated these
markets and sometimes he decided to
repress them but since Kim jong-un came
to power the number of private markets
as multiplied and satellite images show
that they don't stop growing
now the government authorizes many of
these markets in exchange for renting
out spaces to the merchants
yeah that's right the Pyongyang
government is taking advantage of this
new private economy but well how much
well according to the Koreans do for
national unification scam q latians they
get more than two hundred and twenty
thousand American dollars per day so
precisely for this reason recently the
government isn't only promoting these
markets but is also granting visas to
many Chinese entrepreneurs and traders
to further stimulate this economic
activity but dear viewer it does not end
there because well listen to this
[Music]
it isn't only the activity of regulated
markets that's growing it's also that of
the unofficial markets that is those
that don't have the Authority's official
approval the black market see this all
works in the following way
in an economic parallel to the public
sector people make everything they can
shoes sweets clothes and naturally they
try to sell these products in the market
and get money and the currencies they're
hoping for probably yen or even American
dollars but even so it's estimated that
80% of the products sold in North Korean
markets come from China
in other words illegal trade which
happens behind the government's back
also crosses the border and it's
crossing the border in huge and
ever-growing volumes by the way many of
these unofficial markets are becoming a
window to the outside world for many
North Koreans because dear viewer in
these places you can even buy a USB
stick full of foreign movies and shows
including Hollywood productions we saw
foreign programming we had to close all
the doors and curtains and pretend that
there was nobody home danby Kim so you
might now be wondering well contraband
crossing borders why aren't gods and
these security services doing something
about this why are they tolerating this
illegal trade well basically for two
reasons the first is that in Pyongyang
there doesn't seem to be much pressure
to combat these markets and we're going
to see why in a moment and second
because these soldiers and border guards
are also a part of the business and
sometimes they even lend a hand
that's right a common method of payment
according to many of the traders who've
now live outside of North Korea is to
deliver packs of cigarettes stuffed with
money to the police and soldiers while
the fact is that these international
merchants buy products in the North
Korean authorized markets or the black
market and then transfer them to China
sell them and with that money they buy
Chinese products and take them back to
North Korea to sell it's a process as
old as trade itself
[Music]
and here within this world of
international trade is where a new class
is emerging individuals who usually have
power or influence or dealings with high
officials and who are making serious
money and by the way they're driving a
lot of activities that have nothing to
do with the old socialist model within
Pyongyang
itself the salary for doctors was about
3,500 won a month that was less than it
cost to buy one kilogram of rice so of
course being a doctor was not my main
job my main job was smuggling at night I
would send herbal medicine from North
Korea into China and with the money I
would import home appliances back in the
North Korea rice cookers no tells LCD
monitors that kind of thing a doctor who
worked at a hospital in hye-sun North
Korea here's an anecdote today for
example you can buy Coca Cola in the
streets of Pyongyang and according to
the South Korean intelligence service at
least 40% of all North Koreans
participate in private activities and
businesses in some way that might be
surprising to you but there's still more
here but before you get into all of that
here's an important note we're talking
about a very incipient process in North
Korea the government still controls
virtually everything if these black
markets are growing it's because they're
being allowed to grow this is likely
because they're more efficient they work
better they give the government money
and they allow North Koreans to find a
way to improve their living standards
something very similar happens in the
Soviet Union and in Vietnam and of
course in China so now let's have a look
at what else is happening
[Music]
reforms made in China this new class of
merchants and entrepreneurs that is
emerging as a name among North Koreans
the d'Anjou and as you can imagine many
of them especially those who really make
money are people who belong to the
Communist Party and are well-connected
in the government that's to say they are
a part of the elite which they take
advantage of not only to get special
treatment from the security forces but
also to reach advantageous agreements
with public companies there are clear
suspicions that many irregular exports
are manufactured by public companies for
the benefits go to these elite members
however this new economic approach isn't
something that bothers the pyongyang
governments in fact everything indicates
that the North Korean government wants
to reproduce the Chinese model in some
way that is to seek foreign investment
that will allow them to grow and develop
that without losing political control
see since Kim jong-un came to power his
government has granted more freedom to
public companies so that they can
organize as they wish and find their own
suppliers and customers it has also
promoted as we've seen private markets
they turn a blind eye to the black
market and families and collective funds
now have individual plots assigned to
them whose harvest once they meet the
state quota can be used as they wish
they can of course then sell it in the
private market
north Korea has even started talking
about special economic zones but I must
stress here that this is all a very new
process
[Music]
this doesn't mean that a radical change
is going to happen in the short term but
due to the official systems incapacity
the North Koreans are developing an
alternative to improve their standard of
living
and even though unfortunately North
Korea is still the totalitarian and poor
country that it was before Kim Jong Un's
arrival you can't deny that this new
kind of parallel economy's growth is
somewhat surprising so now it's your
time do you think the North Korea will
try to follow the Chinese model well
leave your answer in the comments below
as well as in this survey and I really
hope you enjoyed that video and please
do hit that like button if you did and
don't forget to subscribe to our channel
for brand new videos also don't forget
to check out our friends at the
reconsider Media podcast they provided
the vocals in this episode that were not
mine and as always thank you for
watching
sometimes nothing brings people together
like a nice hot pizza from Pizza
[Music]